salve
alcuni mesi fa gar morena ha scritto un
libro nel quale trae 15 lezioni
dalla dolorosa esperienza della
coronavirus parla della fragilità della
condizione umana
parla del risveglio della solidarietà
eccetera io nel mio piccolo penso si
possa trarre una ulteriore lezione una
sedicesima lezione da questa esperienza
nel senso che dal lob da un dai lunghi
mesi caratterizzati dalle tante
restrizioni dalle difficoltà per
l'economia delle difficoltà per la
scuola dal dolore per chi è scomparso
esce in qualche modo una spinta sorge
una spinta verso il bisogno di cultura
non foss'altro perché da questa da
questo virus stiamo uscendo
grazie alla scienza alla competenza
hanno un certo all'ignoranza questa
crisi ci sta dimostrando l'utilità la
necessità di quello studio matto e
disperatissimo
in cui si sono cimentati in questi mesi
e ancora stanno facendo scienziati e
medici e quindi inevitabilmente serve la
scuola che è il primo luogo in cui si
incontra e si costruisce il sapere
il problema è che soprattutto per le
generazioni nate nel nell'era digitale
la scuola o meglio lo studio scolastico
non è così immediatamente
divertente e semplice perché l'era
digitale ha forgiato il loro stile
cognitivo e quello dello studio
scolastico insomma è leggermente diverso
mi spiego quando noi leggiamo ad esempio
un testo
un file su qualunque device elettronico
di norma è un ipertesto che induce a
procedere per collegamenti per salti
induce meccanismi logici di tipo
associativo
le ragazze i ragazzi si abituano con
tutte le applicazioni sugli smartphone a
risolvere e affrontare
le varie questioni vari problemi
trovando risposte facili divertenti
colorate
nell'era digitale non è necessario
memorizzare informazioni perché si trova
tutto in rete per di più senza nemmeno
bisogno di perdere tempo a digitare
qualche cosa in un motore di ricerca si
può fare affidamento agli assistenti
vocali tipo siri alexa eccetera poi i
ragazzi arrivano a scuola
e qui incontrano mondo fatto di regole
diverse
incontrano un mondo fatto
prevalentemente di lezioni frontali in
cui è
richiesta una concentrazione prolungata
fatto di studio sequenziale e lineare
fatto di ragionamenti perlopiù deduttivi
un mondo nel quale è necessario
memorizzare un sacco di informazioni e
nel quale peraltro c'è l'ansia perché
per la prima volta nella vita si è
sottoposti a frequenti valutazioni e
quindi questo impatto è un po
destabilizzante per alcuni è certamente
faticoso per tutti e in un certo senso
costituisce una spia di questa
difficoltà
le domande che ogni tanto si sentono
formulare soprattutto nel nel gruppo dei
pari del titolo ma cosa serve studiare
questa materia che cosa serve leggere i
promessi sposi o cose di questo genere
sottese a queste domande c'è in realtà
la domanda vera a che cosa serve
studiare a che cosa serve della scuola
allora io faccio il preside
in una scuola superiore e cerco in
particolare primo giorno di scuola
incontrando i nuovi studenti di
trovare assieme a loro le
risposte possibili a queste a queste
domande
in modo da come dire dare quella forza
propulsiva necessaria ad affrontare con
determinazione un percorso di studi
impegnativo ecco di coloro tutti gli
esseri umani crescono ed evolvono in
virtù delle esperienze che fanno nella
vita
e in un certo senso i libri e tra questi
anche i manuali scolastici sono un
concentrato dell'esperienza degli esseri
umani con il vantaggio che noi che li
leggiamo non dobbiamo ripercorrere tutte
quelle esperienze
c'è la storiella di newton che avrebbe
avuto l'intuizione dell'esistenza della
legge di gravitazione in virtù della
mela che gli sarebbe caduta in testa
ecco noi non abbiamo bisogno di
bernoccoli per scoprire che esiste la
legge di gravità è sufficiente appunto
che leggiamo due pagine in un libro di
fisica e così accade per tante altre
cose cioè siamo molto avvantaggiati
rispetto a tutte le generazioni che ci
hanno preceduto perché in un tempo
ragionevolmente breve possiamo acquisire
il patrimonio di esperienze e di
conoscenze di riflessioni che è costato
centinaia di anni vedi appunto di
esperienze in un tempo ragionevolmente
breve le acquisiamo e possiamo partire
dal ii e procedere di procedere oltre
e questa è già una una risposta a quella
domanda
ma come spesso accade gli scrittori sono
ovviamente più bravi e ad esempio in un
altro libro che ho portato lo scrittore
andrea bajani
una decina di anni fa probabilmente ha
scritto un libro da un titolo
provocatorio
la scuola non serve a niente e in due
pagine di questo libro racconta una
esperienza
fatta di colloqui telefonici periodici
con un amico che abita in una città
lontana
durante una di queste occasioni l'amico
lontano racconta lo scrittore
una vicenda un po anomala che gli sta
capitando da pochi giorni ha cambiato la
donna delle pulizie e questa uno strano
comportamento perché gli sposta il
divano che è nel soggiorno
lui lo ricolloca al suo posto ma la
volta dopo di nuovo lo trova spostato
poi le chiacchiere tra gli di due amici
procedono in altre direzioni
in una seconda occasione è lo scrittore
incuriosito chiede all'amico ma com'è
andata a finire la storia della tua
donna delle pulizie che ti sposta il
divano e l'amico dice rientrato a casa
stanco una terza volta la sera non avevo
voglia di spostare il divano che che
provavo collocato in un'altra parete e
mi ci sono seduto sopra e dopo poco mi
sono accorto che guardando in direzione
della finestra riuscivo a vedere un
campanile che prima non vedevo e quindi
ho deciso che quella era la posizione
giusta del divano
bajani conclude la questa metafora
dicendo ecco la scuola non serve a
niente serve a cambiare
la disposizione delle stanze serve a
spostare i mobili e gli insegnanti
devono fare questo tutti i giorni con
pazienza
spostare gli arredi ogni volta che
vedono i loro studenti
aggrappati alla versione cui abituati
perché è dalla
dalla modifica degli schemi mentali che
possono nascere i punti di vista nuovi
sulla realtà e dalla modifica degli
schemi mentali che possono sorgere idee
nuove ed essere stimolata la creatività
e che sono anche ottimi presupposti
appunto per studiare per acquisire il
sapere
la funzione della scuola secondo me non
è come spesso si sente dire anche
diciamo da fonti autorevoli
quella di preparare i giovani al mondo
del lavoro
io penso sia principalmente quella di
arricchire l'esistenza delle persone
perché studiare e apprendere serve ad
espandere la comprensione della realtà
ad approfondire il senso critico ad
abituare a
interrogarci sulle cose
tornando alla metafora del campanile noi
le incontriamo nella vita tutti i giorni
distrattamente nel percorso che facciamo
da da casa al lavoro da casa a scuola
ma pensiamo che cosa può voler dire per
un giovane che ha studiato arte storia
matematica
osservare quel campanile e per la prima
volta
percepire
l'intelligenza dell'architetto che l'ha
costruito
la sapienza del manovale che la
edificato
percepire scorgere la la geometria che
c'è in quel campanile la sezione aurea
le proporzioni
beh quel campanile gli parlerà di
parlerà della sua città noi ad esempio
incontriamo spesso campanili circolari
che è una cosa anomala di dirà qualche
cosa della storia della città di quello
che desideravano gli uomini di
quell'epoca insomma e gli darà anche
qualcosa su l'uso pratico della giunta è
evidente che grazie allo studio noi
capiamo cose nuove e questo non può che
arricchire la nostra vita
d'altro canto aristotele
inizia il primo libro della metafisica
con la frase tutti gli uomini per natura
tendono al sapere e lo fanno perché sono
normalmente spontaneamente incuriositi
delle cose che vedono ed è un'esperienza
se ci pensate che tutti nella nostra
vita abbiamo sperimentato perché c'è in
tutti tutti gli esseri umani la metà dei
perché attorno ai 34 anni i bambini
ossessionano il mondo adulto per sapere
come funzionano certe cose il perché di
questo o di quell'altro quindi c'è in
tutti noi questo desiderio spontaneo di
apprendere poi magari col tempo si
deposita della polvere su questa
attitudine spontanea a conoscere è certo
un bravo insegnante deve risvegliare
quella curiosità innata
certo la scuola deve innovare le
metodologie didattiche e puntare
maggiormente
a quelle metodologie più
innovative più coinvolgenti e tuttavia
non si può addossare solo
dall'insegnante questo difficile compito
shakespeare in pene d'amor perduto fa
dire ad uno dei suoi protagonisti che la
bellezza è nell'occhio di chi guarda
e questo grande autore
penso ci voglia suggerire non soltanto
che la bellezza è un giudizio soggettivo
ma che per riuscire a scorgere la
bellezza bisogna che l'occhio sia
predisposto educato da vederla
la voglia cogliere ecco così nello
studio scolastico bisogna che gli
studenti si approccino allo studio con
quella attitudine che pure hanno
sperimentato alcuni anni alcuni anni
prima
e questo aiuta anche a sopportare la
fatica dello studio perché il rovescio
della medaglia è che accanto
all'entusiasmo che può esserci nella
scoperta di un idea nuova del dvd un
concetto nuovo
certamente poi c'è la fatica di dover e
memorizzare le informazioni doverle
organizzare mentalmente per poterle
utilizzare
e questo richiede il rapporto quotidiano
con i libri di testo quegli esercizi con
le traduzioni sono comunque un'attività
certamente non divertenti
antonio gramsci che probabilmente si è
aiutato a sopportare le fatiche del
carcere grazie allo studio cui era
appassionatamente dedicato
dei suoi quaderni
definisce lo studio come un abito che si
acquisisce con lo sforzo
e io cerco di rendere fruibile questo
concetto agli adolescenti facendo un
parallelismo con l'attività sportiva che
molti praticano con un con grande
entusiasmo anche nello sport c'è il
momento diciamo dell'entusiasmo che
normalmente è quello della gara perché
c'è il pubblico che fa il tifo perché
c'è
la voglia di mettersi in gioco
l'adrenalina che scorre nelle vene
però quella performance atletica è
possibile perché prima c'è stata la
ripetizione infinita del gesto atletico
fintanto che non diventa un automatismo
perché prima c'è stata
l'allenamento necessario per acquisire
la forza muscolare la resistenza fisica
insomma
nello sport come nella scuola
probabilmente nella vita
l'entusiasmo e la fatica diciamo sono
elementi intrinsecamente
collegati
come nello studio anche nello sport
possono esserci gare che non vanno come
si vorrebbe
e anche nello studio scolastico non
bisogna abbattersi se una verifica non
va come si vorrebbe perchè sandra edgar
morin in un altro libro ci spiega che in
ambito scolastico l'errore è
sovrastimato è considerato una mancanza
mentre l'errore non è un
parassita esterno della facoltà
cognitive e intrinseco al processo di
conoscere e dunque non è la prova di un
fallimento è un'informazione utile a
migliorare
e mantenendo il parallelismo con lo
score c'è però una grande differenza tra
la performance appunto atletica e quella
scolastica perché nello sport possono
vincere in pochi nella scuola
spiego sempre possono vincere tutti
possono vincere tutti perché vincere non
è salire su un podio ristretto e
migliorare il proprio punto di partenza
se al termine di un periodo che può
essere un anno scolastico
qualche cosa altro un ragazzo si rende
conto di essere in grado di concepire
pensieri che prima non aveva di essere
più consapevole di se stesso di avere
nuove abilità ha vinto la propria gara
indipendentemente dai voti ottenuti a
scuola e concludo con una citazione del
premio nobel per l'economia robert solow
vi in un discorso tenuto qualche anno fa
al mit di boston
dove ha detto noi siamo quello che
conosciamo
noi siamo quello che conosciamo e anche
la ricchezza di un paese dipende dalle
competenze che acquisiscono le nuove
generazioni allora è evidente che i
giovani sono per la società il bene più
prezioso l'investimento importante
e diciamo il loro valore sia cresce
proporzionalmente a livello di
acculturazione ma più in generale una
società migliore
se i suoi cittadini sono colti
consapevoli istruiti e chiaramente un
percorso lungo e difficile ma vale la
pena di compiere davvero tutti gli
sforzi per incoraggiarlo e sostenerlo
grazie
[Applauso]